so i'll repeat that members have before
them something marked replacement this
is the replacement map and data for the
rockingham county commissioners that we
reviewed yesterday it was discovered
that
a portsmouth ward had dropped so you can
substitute this for what you have in
your packet from yesterday so we kept
that separate
you also have in front of you something
that's been packed passed out by
mapathon they passed out something
yesterday in regards to house districts
today they have passed out something for
you in regards to the congressional
districts you also have in front of you
a map of grafton county representatives
as proposed by representative fellows
that is separate from your committee
packet information
and then you should have a new
spreadsheet which picks up
after
it continues from where we left
yesterday and begins with what we will
be doing today
you will note that number 19 is there
and you might want to go to the bottom
of your stack of papers for today
uh
19.
is the
commissioner maps
that representative lane so kindly
agreed would be provided
these represent
a proposed map which is no change from
the current map
so you will now have
the lines for the current map and the
associated numerical
calculation
to
with the proposed maps we reviewed
yesterday so that's why that packet is
designated as 19 you can sort and
compare
as you
desire which leaves us
numbers 12 through 18 on your list to
review
that would include county
representatives for grafton
stratford
hillsborough
cheshire carol and sullivan
and the congressional district maps
and you should have gotten emails for
all of those yesterday and you have hard
copies of them before you today
for the rep maps um
it is my understanding that the a's are
those proposed by the
minority members of the committee and
the b's are the
those maps proposed by the
majority members
they do not have the names like they had
on yesterday does anybody have any
questions in regards to the paperwork
and follow-up from yesterday before we
i just had i just had one
regarding the maps on the website i
understand that those still are not up
there and i
wondered if you could give us a briefing
on
what is going on with the website so
that uh
you know we've we've been promised
representatives
i don't know that anybody makes any
promises when you're dependent on
somebody else promises are
probably not a great thing as you might
know though you were not here yesterday
we've been having some problems with eit
site since it was converted to a new
format for the entire house
yesterday during the meeting we
managed to get solve the issue of
finally getting the submitted testimony
up
and by the end of the meeting when you
clicked on the submitted testimony you
could actually open it
there were discussions about
communicating with it i take full
responsibility for shutting my computer
off at about 10 20 last night
and when i was in bed and realized i had
not officially sent an email request i
did not have the energy to get up and
turn my computer back on
so this morning before i did anything
else i did turn my computer on and sent
the email it was aware of the issue i
have proposed a format
for the maps to be placed on the website
and it's my hope that that will be
done by the end of our meeting today
but again i am entirely dependent on i.t
and their ability to address the issue i
know that they have been told this is a
priority to deal with this page so it is
my hope uh that the maps as proposed by
members will be up certainly by the end
of the day certainly by the end of the
week so
representative weber that's where we are
thank you very much i just i'm very
mindful that the public needs to be able
to see them in order to be able to
present any kind of meaningful and of
course we've had paper copies here
available for people who are here
so
we expect the i.t issues to be resolved
today but then again you're looking at
the person who did sit at her computer
at 10 o'clock on monday night and
clicked on the website and went oh no so
we're we're making progress everybody so
we're doing the best we can
all right
all right so we will start with review
of the
maps
for the representatives um just for
purposes i i guess we'll just go
alphabetically
as we go through them it'll just make it
a little easier to follow along since
that's how though this isn't quite how
it was put together for today
um because i do think carol comes before
cheshire but we will go with a
which would be cheshire
and
i don't
cheshire should be 12 and there's a 12 a
and b it is first on our list for the
the today um and why don't we start with
who is going to speak to the a map
representative marjorie smith thank you
yes thank you very much madam chair and
thank you for your
efforts to
try to
do what i think we all want to have
happen and that's make this information
available
uh
to the state um
i am
now presenting
a proposal
for
house maps for cheshire county
and uh as an introduction i want to say
that as we worked on these maps
in addition to the constitutional and
statutory requirements
we had um
some initial goals one was to make house
districts as small as possible
for many reasons
many of the people who testified before
our 10 listening sessions
asked for that
um it is uh
the larger a district is
the more expensive it is for a candidate
to run and since trying to get 400
highly qualified well 800 highly
qualified people to run in a small state
is hard
the smaller the districts are is the
better
i also want to make the point that as we
try to make a fair map
we certainly do not claim to make a
perfect map
particularly in small counties such as
cheshire there are a lot of problems
because we can't cross county borders
and because towns that are on the border
give fewer choices for combinations
so
understanding that
it we don't claim perfection
but we
claim the best that we could come up
with
the um the cheshire map that we're
presenting includes 18
total districts
14 are base districts and
four
are
floaterial
and that is for 22
seats
and
i'm going to go quickly through them
because i think it helps
members of the committee as well as
those who are listening
district 1 has two seats and it's
gilsum surrey wallpal and westmoreland
district two has one seat
alstead marlow stoddard and sullivan
districts three through seven
are the keen wards
and they're five awards and each one has
one seat
um district 8 is dublin harrisville
nelson and roxbury 1 seat
district 9 is jeffrey and marlborough
one seat
district 10 is rindge one seat this is a
new town that gets its own based
district
a goal that so many people asked us to
follow
district 11 is fitzwilliam richmond
swansea and troy for
three seats
each of these towns sends their high
schoolers to monadnock regional high
school
district 12 chesterfield
one seat that is also a new town that
gets its own district
district 13 is winchester one seat which
is what exists now
14 is
hinsdale one seat this is a new town
that gets its own base district
then we have district
15 which is a one
seat floaterial
of
keane wards two and three and
district 16 is a one sea floaterial of
keen wards one four and five
district 17 is a two-seat floaterial
of jeffrey marlborough
um
and uh and rindge
jeffrey and rinch send their
high schoolers to connor high school
district 18 is a one-seat flow terial
of
districts 11 13 and 14.
so the net result is that this map
increases the number of single seat
districts from 11 as exists now
to 15
and the total deviation for the proposed
and that is the best that we could do
and if
someone has some suggestions to make it
better we are
the colors are helpful but it's still
i just have a question representative
smith i thought at the beginning you
said 14 base
single districts is it
15 or 14. um wait i have to go back here
it's not willing representative weber do
you have an answer to the 14 base
and four
and one of one of the floaters had two
members
which is sometimes unusual but makes the
all right any questions or
for representative smith any comments on
okay i'm not seeing any so
on page 12 b there is
a proposed map for house representatives
for cheshire county
and i'm going to ask the other
representative smith to address those
representative steve smith
thank you madam chair
in public testimony in cheshire one of
the things we heard was
that the river towns should be kept
together this plan accomplishes that
it isn't a rule but
i don't like to treat city wards
differently than others by peeling one
or two off and combining them with other
towns we look for opportunities to do
that to keep them together honestly in
all parts of the state it's just simply
not possible but in this one it was
kings numbers all by themselves
don't get them there but if you add the
channel to marlborough you pre get a
pretty good seven seat district
and advantage there also is that since
the committee voted to use the equalized
ward values with this plan we don't care
how it ends up because it doesn't affect
anything else
there is only one fletcherial and that's
at the bottom where the
the numbers were low and we had to put a
bunch of different towns together but
overall it's laid out pretty well
geographically um in the blue towns
that's a four seat district
candidates will campaign up and down the
connecticut river
the top right is put together those are
excuse me representative smith i have to
ask by blue do you mean purple
no he means light blue
oh light blue okay thank you light blue
oh do we have shoe blues well no i just
wanted to make sure that the river's on
the left yeah the river the river ones
are blue right and the river's on the
left right that's right okay they are
and some of the those are some of the
towns that have given rise that the best
thing about vermont is the view across
the river
uh so overall that's it uh only we could
accomplish this with only one fliterial
i just wondered aside from the
issue of the river towns why the
why the decision was made even even
including the river towns
to reject the constitutional mandate of
the
areas that have enough to have their own
reps
which has been rejected in 13 of the 14
towns that really ought to have their
own i mean i know it's mathematically
impossible to do all of them but
what what was the thinking on those
um well do you have an example um
i know a lot of people believed walpole
was but it's not actually
a constitutionally mandated town because
it's not within what's generally
accepted for a one-district deviation
it's a little over
i understand that but the constitutional
mandate makes no
earthly sense
if you hold that it means that only
those towns which are within a constitu
within the exact deviation
are entitled to local representation
and that anything that exceeds
that is not entitled to local
representation that seems to make a
mockery of what
certainly the people who talk to me when
that was being voted in
thought they were voting on
i understand that walpole is slightly
too high
it is alas too high by only
16 people
and i'm pretty sure that all 16 of those
people would gladly agree to be
underrepresented if they could have
their very own district but
i understand that
thoughts differ on that and and i
understand that the deviation needs to
be accounted for so
that's what happens in in the other plan
yeah and i think we don't try to achieve
that though at the expense of the rest
of the county or having the county
numbers go over 10 percent overall i
respectfully think we just see it
differently probably
i've made my point so we're good
anybody else
on this 12b for cheshire or
anything
okay
the next one in our packet is carol
um
carol why don't we start with
thank you madam chair good morning
everybody
our map of carroll county
has a total of
eight death eight districts
the
total deviation is minus
4.84 to
minus 0.37 for an overall 4.4
the districts and the towns within the
districts are laid out of course
on
pages immediately following
the map
and other than that
any questions for representative
turcotte
all right there may be questions
after that uh
carroll
county representative map a
would speak to that
representative bergeron right thank you
madam chair
um i'll go through all the districts
because i know anybody that might be
watching this online now or later won't
have maps to refer to so uh and i'll
make comments where i think it adds some
relevant information
the proposed map includes ten total
districts seven are base and three floor
tyrio
with a total of 15 seats
district one would include bartlett
hearts location in jackson with one seat
and that's the same as the existing
district
district 2 albany chatham conway hales
location and sandwich for three seats
district 3 madison and tamworth
during the public input sessions a
speaker noted that tamworth shared
interest with madison to the east and
sandwich to the west so those two towns
are paired
district four would include brookfield
eaton effingham freedom and wakefield
which would receive two seats
district five would be moultonborough
which is now eligible to
receive its its own base district its
own seat dedicated seat
district six would be ossipee again
ossipee is a town that now gets its own
base district based on population
changes
district seven tufton borough and
wolfeboro are put together for two seats
both towns send high schoolers to
kingswood high
tufton borough sits in between three
towns it could have had could have their
own districts based on popular
population so
decision was to pair it with wolfeboro
and give molten burrow and ossipee their
own own seats district eight is a
one-seat floaterial of districts one and
two
district nine is a two-seat floaterial
of districts three three to five
and district ten is a one-seat
floaterial
of districts six and seven
and um
all three towns and this floater will
send their high schoolers to kingswood
high so they have a
common interest common connection there
as well
the map increases the number of
districts in the county from eight to
ten instead of one seven town filterial
and one eleven town floaterial the
proposed map creates three floaters
containing three towns four towns and
eight towns
total deviation for the proposed map is
thank you madam chair
some of the districts are the same any
okay i'm not seeing any so that is
and
who's going to be doing 14 a grafton
that would be oh that's right
representative bergeron okay
thank you madam chair
uh
the proposed map for grafton includes 15
total districts
14 base and one full terial with a total
of 26 districts and again i'll identify
the contents of each district and
highlight any any elements that i
thought led to the decision of pairing
certain towns
district one would include littleton and
monroe with two seats
bethlehem and franconia for one seat are
put together in district two
currently they're in two separate
districts but both towns send their high
schoolers to profile high
district 3
eastern land of lisbon lyman and sugar
hill would
have one seat
district 4
puts together bath benton haverhill and
piermont with two seats
and all four towns send their high
schoolers to woodsville high
district 5 would be two seats containing
ellsworth lincoln livermore thornton
warren waterville and woodstock
district six would contain orford rumney
and wentworth
for one seat
district seven remains the same campton
receives one seat
district eight puts together ashland
holding this in plymouth for two seats
and all three towns send their high
schoolers to plymouth high school
district nine pairs bridgewater and
bristol for one seat
district 10 puts together alexandria
grafton groton and hebron one seat
district 11 canaan dorchester and orange
one seat
district 12 remains the same enfield uh
receives one seat and it's uh
it's
what it is formed as now
district 13 again same as it exists
currently it's hanover and lime for four
seats both towns send their high
schoolers to a hanover high
lebanon remains the same as a
city district with four seats district
15 is a one-seat floaterial
consisting of districts 9 through 12
and all the towns that send high
schoolers to muscoma valley regional are
included in this floaterial
the map prioritizes single-seat
districts as much as possible and the
total deviation for the proposed map is
7.48
i also wanted to acknowledge
the map that was emailed to the
committee by representative sally
fellows recently and we have copies i
think aren't tables
we get a lot a massive amount of
material and i'm only acknowledging it
because i i like it to kind of percolate
to the top of the massive volume of
paper that we we have before us
what i found interesting or intriguing
is that the largest district in her
proposal contains six towns
whereas there's a ten-town flow terial
in
both proposals 14a and 14b
[Music]
she also had creates fewer districts 13
versus the 15 and 18 districts and the
other two plans before us
one of the downsides is that the town of
enfield which is entitled to a seat of
its own uh is included in a six-town
cluster and you know
we've been taking the position that we
should create districts for towns that
have sufficient population for their own
representative and that's been an
important criteria for us in the
development of maps
but again i thought the approach was
intriguing there were fewer districts
there were smaller districts and i just
would encourage members to at least take
a look at it and see if there's anything
that appeals to them as we head toward
our executive sessions on these bills
thank you madam chair thank you
representative bergeron any questions on
i'm not
seeing any
so
14b grafton representative turcotte i
think you're speaking to this one
thank you madam chair uh grafton county
we end up with uh
18 districts
and two floats
again i am not going to read them all
off hopefully these will be up on the
website
soon for everybody who wants to look at
them to see
uh
other than that
oh and the deviation range sorry minus
3.91 to 4.53 for a total deviation of
8.44
representative lane uh yes i i realize
um we're not he's not reading out
the towns but could you talk about
what the priorities were when you put
together this map
our priorities was developing maps that
priorities
parameters that we've set by vote in
this committee
all our maps have been
developed using the same criteria
but other than that i'm not going to get
into the
okay yeah representative weber
oh i think representative mcguire was
before me
oh sorry
thank you uh i was just wanted to
comment that the two maps are actually
extremely similar
minor changes minor changes in the float
aside
the
[Music]
the 14b has more districts because it
divided
gave lebanon four districts instead of
one dividing each ward and then then a
afloat
so assuming their their awards are good
they will get
they'll therefore their four
representatives will run in four
different districts rather than at large
but
it's remarkable how similar the two maps
thank you
okay the next one on our list is 15a
and i see two names on the list
representative bergeron and
representative wilhelm
um i will defer to representative
wilhelm to take the lead on this um
he's
from the northern part of the of the
county and uh i'll be happy to weigh in
on the southern part
and i hope you do
okay thank you
uh thank you madam chair so my proposed
house map for hillsborough county it
includes 46 total districts 38 base
eight floaterall
district one
includes antrim deering hillsborough and
windsor for three seats
hillsborough and deering shara high
school
district two is
bennington francistown greenfield and
hancock
all four of those towns send their high
schoolers to conval
convale high school
uh district three
is where it's two seats
district four is goffstown which is four
seats
uh district five is wideneborough
mount vernon and new boston for three
seats
uh district six is bedford for seven
and then we start to get into manchester
so there are two seats
for each ward and base district
district 19
is litchfield two seats
same as existing
uh
merrimack is the same eight seats same
as existing
uh amherst three seats milford four
seats those are all same as the existing
districts
district 23 is temple and wilton that is
one seat
district 24 is peterborough and sharon
for two seats
both of those towns send their high
schoolers to conval
district 25 is new ipswich one suite one
seat
and that is a new town that would get
its own base district
district 26
is
brookline greenville
and mason for two seats
district 27 is hollis
uh two seats that's the same as existing
uh
and then we start to get into nashua
so uh it's three seats in each ward
uh
and those are the same as existing
uh fast forward to
district 37
hudson six seats
this is a new town that would get its
own base district
district 38 is pelham for four seats
another town that would get its own base
district
district 39
uh is where we start to get into flow
cereals so
uh there's a two seat flow tyrial that's
goffstown and where
together
all right
okay are we okay
that's good i wanna make sure i get it i
got my head down i'm sorry everybody i'm
going back and forth so if you have and
let me know if i'm going too fast
yeah
um
okay so that was 39
district 40
is where we get into flow
cereals for manchester now
as previously i'm right now currently in
district 42. my floateria would change
that gets a little bit a little bit
harder for me to seek re-election it's a
good fair map
district 40 is a three seat flow terial
that's composed of manchester words one
and two
district 41
would be a three-seat floaterial
manchester awards five
and seven through nine
the new district 42 would be a
three-seat floaterial which would be
manchester ward's three so that's
downtown the mill yard
uh and all of the west side wards 10 11
and 12. so they all share the river
there
uh district 43 a two-seat floaterial
composed of hudson and litchfield
district 44
would be a one-seat floaterial composed
district 45
the one seat floaterial composed of new
and last but not least
district 46
a one sea floaterial composed of
brookline greenville hollis and mason
uh hollis and brookline they share a
so you know a few features of this map
uh map keeps manchester and nashua
completely separate from other towns and
base districts and influence
if you feel like it's a good thing
um the map separates pelham and hudson
uh something that we've heard a lot
about not just during this process but
over the last decade
and the map also increases the number of
towns with their own base districts
there are 15 total in this map total
deviation 9.17
percent
um and just a note
about manchester
uh you know our our total population is
115 844.
um you divide that by our magic number
uh and you get just over over 33 so you
know both 33 or 34 reps for manchester
within that 10 range of deviation
um
and i'm obviously pretty partial to it
because it keeps manchester whole i'm
anything to add representative bergeron
um
actually you did a very good job the
only thing i might point out is that 26
of the 46 districts are unchanged and i
think given the
volume of seats we're dealing with
okay
anybody else on 15 a
representative porter
i don't know if i'm on or not
red button down
i don't have a red button
christina can you hear representative
porter
can you hear me now yes that seemed to
amplify a bit um
i wanted to thank um
make a mention here given that
the northern part of hillsborough county
is what i represent so i have a pretty
good feel for what's going on when i
look at this map
and i would i'm very grateful to see
that the 10-town floatarial district
that includes hillsborough currently
goes from hillsborough all the way down
to greenville which is eliminated on
this map
ten towns is
for a flotarial
is a huge
thing and i'm glad to see that in this
this map it's gone it was hard to
represent all those ten towns
and i'm pleased to see that it was a
consideration to include the town of uh
deering with the towns of hillsboro and
windsor because we have a lot of common
interests and we know
we and they they really do belong
together they're almost one community so
i want to say thank you
to in this plan to those considerations
because they make a big difference in
whoever is elected to represent
that area of the state
thank you
all right
turning to 15 b is a hillsborough map
for county representatives also
representative turcotte or barry
turcotte okay thank you madam chair uh
hillsborough county we have it at a
total
of 45 districts
one
one note on the city of manchester
instead of floating
four cities together
four wards sorry
[Music]
instead of floating the four wards
together we floated three
together
of course nashua each one of those words
gets their own
representative
and our overall deviation on here is
negative
5.01 to positive
questions for representative turcotte
representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair i'm curious your
your map has i think 32 seats is that
right for the city of manchester
that's correct okay
um
i guess i'm just i'm curious uh it seems
like either 33 or 34 would be
appropriate based on population size you
know both 33 or 34 would be
within
generally accepted deviation
um is there a reason
that
manchester appears to be slightly
underrepresented
uh manchester the deviation on the
individual
awards come in at 4.94
which is
within the deviation ranges that we're
using
as compared to the overall deviation is
that what you're talking about
representative yeah just overall
deviation within the county okay so it's
a question of individual versus overall
representative porter did you have your
thank you for taking my question oops
i'm having a problem here today
but no i'm okay good um
again i want to bring up the fact that
in this map there is a nine-town
floatario um it is not as geographically
spread out as the ten-town floataria
that's current however it is a lot of
towns and difficult
to represent
so i'm concerned about that
and also looking at these
these maps i'm seeing
some districts
that are becoming more of one color in
terms of political
stan political point of view than they
just knowing this area of the state
pretty well
i'm pretty concerned about
the groupings of certain towns together
and the reasons why that was occurring
so i just want to bring that forward i
know we don't
try to get ourselves reelected but
it seems like
something like that might have been in
the works with looking at this map
okay
that was 15 that was hillsborough
next we have stratford
oh i'm sorry representative wilhelm
there i am with my head down again
i just have a question
one thing i'd be curious to know
uh
with all of our maps is if there are any
um
i i think they're they're minority
majority
districts and i suppose because we're
talking about hillsborough county i'd
just be curious to know if
we've taken a look at that to make sure
that we're
in compliance with with federal laws
around that
specifically nashua i think that's where
madam chairman i'd be able to give some
insight into that thank you
representative barry um yes
representative so um i believe it was
the first or second one of our meetings
you guys made reference to this so i um
loaded up the
database into an access program
and i ran um every voting location ward
town right um in the state to see what
is
this is obviously an extremely sensitive
issue but
you know the the
most um
the least white right um
and the
the most racially diverse area in the
state that i was able to find was
actually manchester's ward 5
which was 55 percent white and that was
when you removed hispanic and latino
from the the census will put hispanic
and latino into
the white character the white categories
catechur excuse me
categorization that's the nice stutter
there um
so that it's actually manchester it's
actually our home city uh it's
manchester's uh manchester ward five
and because there is to my knowledge at
least the the
the analysis that i did there is no
voting single voting location in the
state that has a majority minority
population now that may change in 10
years from manchester's ward 5 but as of
today i don't because you guys made
mention of that you would like to look
at that so i went and i looked at it and
i don't know how you would do it without
actually going in and breaking up a ward
now once again that could change when
they redraw the ward lines but we're
operating underneath the current ward
lines that's right so maybe uh
there could be a provision within
uh
the house
bill that that
looks at at the house maps
to to account for that
um
it may not be necessary this time around
so maybe are you saying that it's not
necessary in this redistricting but it
could be in 10 years
absolutely in 10 years because we don't
know what the future will hold um but
you know if the the state went from i
think
92 or 93 white to 87 and 0.9 or
something like that overall
and my my quick analysis of that change
was that it was done basically on the
category the the largest growth was
hispanic and mixed race
um
but it's you know if manchester awards
fi i believe number two was awarded
nashua and the award escapes me right
now um but they if i recall and i'm kind
of digging in the cobwebs it's been a
couple of months since i've looked at
this but that ward was in the 60s in
terms of um
total total percent white
but i don't know how to your point about
a provision or a clause i don't know how
we would be able to predict the future
of what they're going to do this time
around but to your point about in 10
years
it absolutely could be something to look
at in 10 years but that's a problem for
not a problem but that's an issue for 10
years down the road
just quick follow-up sure is is there
any guidance that we should be providing
the cities of
manchester or nashua as they redraw
their lines as it relates to this
i i would leave that to the individual
city that i'm i'm per on on my opinion
i'm not ready to issue guidance to any
city or town to draw lines along race
that's something that makes me
very uncomfortable
i believe that would be far beyond the
jurisdiction of anything this committee
does
anybody else on issues before we move on
and it's my intent that we are going to
take a short break after this map
all right representative turca
thank you madam chair
uh stratford county
we developed a map with 21 districts
uh four floaterials
we have an overall deviation range of
minus 4.2 to plus
overall deviation for stratford
county
any questions
i'm we're going to move on to
b
oh 16 a sorry and that will be
representative marjory smith thank you
very much madam
chair as a proud resident of stratford
county
i'm delighted to present this to you i
want to
stress again that
in addition to the constitutional and
legislative requirements
we worked very very hard to have smaller
districts to have single member
districts
to make it easier for
citizens
to relate to their
representatives
and we acknowledge that these maps are
not perfect
i do want to make one additional comment
in terms of the
state constitutional requirement
about
ensuring that any district that
meets the
appropriate number is entitled to
be
have its own district
i believe that we will
find that there's a little difference of
opinion here there are some people who
seem to think that the count
of that particular town would have to be
exactly
the number
which in this case is you know the 3404
number
but in fact
i believe that the intention is that
that is a minimum
it is not
uh to say that if you were over that you
couldn't have your one and then
the additional are handled the way we
handle everything you know combining in
some ways with other
other districts so following that
um
we have 25 total districts
18 base
and seven floateral districts and that
is a total of 38 seats
district one is farmington middleton
milton and new durham for four seats
district two
is i'm very pleased to say
stratford for one seat
this is a new town that gets its own
base district
and
is no longer connected by
a point
on a square with another town in order
to create a larger district
district three is barrington with two
seats which is the same as the existing
district and district four is lee with
one seat again the same as the existing
district
durham and madbury
have five seats again the same as the
existing district
in rochester each of the wards and there
are six wards have one seat
the same as the existing district
in dover there's a slight difference in
dover wards one through four
each have one seat which is the same as
the existing district
but also we add dove award five with one
seat and dove award six with one seat
where in the past they had been combined
with other jurisdictions
rollins ford and somersworth
have
four
seats together
and they are not combined with dover
which
seems to us to be a much more fair and
equitable distribution of seats
then we have um
district 19 has one floaterio
um
that's made up of districts one and two
district 22 was one float
the 21 has one floateria which is
rochester wards one and two
district 22 has won filterial of
rochester wards three and four
uh district three is one floaterial of
rochester wards five and six
district 24 has two seats
floateria
composed of dove awards one five and six
and
the last district is 25 with a two-seat
floaterall composed of dove awards two
and four
this map separates dover
somersworth and rollinsford something
that has been an issue
in the existing map
and it keeps rochester separate from
other towns in any base or floaterial
district
and it separates as i said before
stratford from new durham in the base
district which currently only connects
geographically at a single point
it is my hope that
my distinguished colleague
who was the clerk of judiciary committee
is
listening to this and is secretly or
publicly cheering that we have
recognized that stratfor should be there
on its own
the total deviation um for the proposed
map is
9.85
thank you
questions representative mcguire
just one minor correction
rollinsford is not separate from
somersworth it's combined with it it's
the same district that the other map has
if they are separate from dover that's
correct
this has to do with i think is referred
to as the ox oxford
comma or is it the cambridge comma
in that um
uh
by that statement those two
are together and then dover is and the
and without the comma makes things
confusing exactly i was just wanted to
clarify that point because a lot of
people were concerned about that at the
anybody else
all right that's
16 a and 16 b
uh so we have 17 a and b and 18 a and we
are going to take a short break we will
be back here
specifically
the city and
that's what i thought
and then i but i
saw one of our maps where lebanon was
okay
oh
i know well i just wanted to let you
know but it seems to go more smoothly
until three days later
all right christina let's get going
all right we are on
all right thank you everybody for that
uh recess which of course like all good
recesses went longer than i said it
would i apologize it is now 11 15.
all right uh we left off with 16 we are
now on 17.
this is sullivan county
um and i am going to turn to
representative steve smith
for sullivan
b
thank you madam chair
sullivan has challenging geography
one of the first thing you notice is the
two largest municipalities by far
clermont and newport like a wall down
the middle it is challenging to make
better numbers by combining northern and
southern towns
one of the things that we heard was that
grantham should have its own
representative they are just a smidge
over a one percent deviation they should
this plan does that
uh we heard
multiple people testify that sunapee
should have its own representative they
are under three percent off from being
perfect this plan gives them their own
representative
we also heard that claremont should stay
together
this plan does that there's literally no
change to the voting districts in
claremont
separating them from the towns
is important
people know a lot about headline news
but what happens at the county level is
our pitched battles are over whether the
fall mountain food shelf gets the county
grant or the claremont soup kitchen does
local transportation issues the city and
the towns often have widely disparate
viewpoints on that
if i represented both claremont and one
of the towns when we had one of our
biggest battles over the local buses i
would have had to have asked myself
which of my constituents do i ignore
because they're on opposite sides so
this plan makes good sense that way
what stays the same
at the bottom of the county currently
charlestown
all of those orange towns that you see
in the plan
and goshen
are one district without unity um and
afflicterial and then the orange ones
plus goshen would without unity would be
a separate district the only change
there at all is that goshen and unity
are swapped
this makes good sense because newport
and goshen have very close ties goshen
kids go to newport schools a lot of
people live in goshen work in newport
it's right down the road
that leaves some things to deal with um
oh another thing
the last criticism of the current state
of affairs that we had was a giant
floaterial ignore the colors but notice
where claremont is now start right above
that those towns are on the vermont
border
go all the way right to the merrimack
county border
down and then come back under klama
almost back to the vermont border that's
currently a nine town fliterial nobody
likes it
the uh we heard the representative that
represents it doesn't like it
i don't like it it's it's just
the fallout from dealing with the
numbers last time so what this plan does
is
we have smaller footerials there are two
no way to do sullivan without them
they are comprised of towns we don't use
claremont wards peel it apart and piece
those anywhere
and uh i think this makes good sense the
i don't know what to call the color it's
kind of pink at the top
that is a product of carving grantham
out for its own rep and then making
sense of what remains
people may question whether or not
newport and cornish are contiguous
they are
in sound records going back many decades
apparently when perambulation happens
when the town officials are supposed to
walk the borders they would meet out
there and have lunch that was pretty
cool there's a marker in the ground out
there and one property owner
owns land in three of the towns so that
certainly meets the definition
is it ideal
no
but i think that the other
considerations i cited at the beginning
are the important ones and the
priorities and doing this was necessary
to accomplish that overall deviation is
thank you i always like to hear about
perambulation i have done a few myself
they're quite an exercise
and i believe we have tried to get there
have been attempts to get rid of it um
here at the state house a couple of
times over the years and it never
succeeds
okay questions for representative steve
and if there are none i think we are
going to representative marjorie smith
thank you very much um the smiths have
cornered the market on sullivan county
and i
and we agree on the underlying
point that it is unbelievably difficult
to do
sullivan county you wonder why it
doesn't you know on the one hand this
and on the other hand that
um and some of the changes that we've
made are the same changes that in april
the same changes that um my colleague
made but but not all of them
and again we're trying to keep these
districts as small as possible
but it doesn't it just doesn't
necessarily work
i mean we can end up with a very good
deviation
range of 3.73 total which is is
wonderful
but
there are problems getting to it we have
sixth base and two floateral and we have
a total of 13 seats
district one is cornish and plainfield
district 2 is grantham one seat this is
a
new town that gets its own base district
and
the other map that was just proposed
does exactly the same thing
district three is springfield and
sunapee with one seat
district four
is
claremont and croydon
with three seats it keeps claremont
together which is difficult to
accomplish but not claremont alone
i'm sorry to say
district 5 is charleston newport and
unity for three seats
six is acworth goshen langdon leemster
and washington for one seat
and then um
the floaterials uh
district seven is a one
seat
floaterial
um
with uh
cornish
and
uh
and playing field and
um
oh i'm drowning in papers i'm sorry
five
oh i'm sorry in charleston
uh
for the float for some
where point me
oh charleston cornish
newport plainfield and
unity
okay is that it
um
and uh
oh i'm sorry and district eight which is
um
so it's tough
we agree on that we did the best that we
can do we'd be happy to have some
suggestions for
getting it better and i'm delighted for
grantham that we both agree we all agree
that that's a good place to have a seat
thank you just uh because representative
smith had papers the
the bigger float i believe is acworth
claremont corydon goshen langdon lobster
springfield centipede and washington
which is a mouthful no wonder i couldn't
say exactly that's happy to help out so
all right any questions for either of
the smiths
on sullivan county
representative lane
ask a question um i noticed when
representative
steven smith was speaking about
claremont and keeping it together the
differences
and we tried to do that as well but that
didn't seem to hold in stratfor county
when we talked about rochester and dover
and i guess this is really more of a
question
i guess for representative turcotte was
there a way to do that to keep dover and
stratfor
i'm sorry dover and rochester together
without the
um
including border towns or you know
so i'm just asking that question
because i know we were all trying to do
that
i'm sorry i'm backtracking i was just
listening
no that's fine okay i think in just
about every county we could come up with
variations of
putting this town with that
town or this town with that town ward it
doesn't work the same in every county
could have been done in stratford i'm
i'm sure there's some possibility of
doing that that doesn't necessarily mean
that
that option is any better than any
representative steve smith please
thank you madam chair
yeah i think i think what i said too is
it's something we want to do but
sometimes we're prevented but like like
keane there was no way to make keen its
own thing so you had two options you
could peel off the wards and put them
with other things or just add the one i
don't remember what the talent was um to
it
thank you everybody knows about me and i
that just seems to work out that way
a good trade-off
other questions
sullivan county but others
to the extent we can remember
because it has been a lot of paperwork
all right i'm not seeing any so we're
going to move on to the last map on the
agenda for today
and that would be
number 18 the whole state the
congressional district we have a few
more pages to this because of course
it's every community listed in the
paperwork
and
why don't we
start with is it one
so if you look at the congressional
district it will look
it will look a lot like the map as it
currently exists
uh goals here uh were to keep both
congressional districts
uh in a way to remain competitive
mirroring the state as a whole
there have been minimal changes in
population between the existing
districts
since the last census
so the map should also make minimal
changes
the existing congressional districts
have remained very very similar for the
last 14 decades 140 years and the only
changes
that have been made to balance
uh in the the only real changes that
have been made over the last 140 years
have been changes uh to balance the
population between the two districts
as the maps are currently drawn as of
the 2020 elections the population of cd1
is 17
people
larger
than congressional district number two
so in order to balance the populations
of the two districts this proposed map
moves a single town hempstead
population 8998
from cd1 to cd2
the resulting difference in population
is just 51 people now between the two
districts
this proposed map continues to keep both
districts competitive and continues with
the long history
of not making changes in the districts
other than balancing population
thanks
and the print is really small nothing
that you had any control of
so can you just point out which blue
spot is hampstead
if anybody can
madam sherman's hampstead's in the
southern tier well i knew it's in the
southern tier so it's going to be next
to deary
and it's a wonderful town madam chairman
hampstead is a wonderful town
all right i'm seeing like somebody just
hit a goal down there with
representative simpson
it's like a square except that it opens
up like
at the top
does that make sense so somebody just
hold up a map and point to the general
area that it is bottom right it's this
one so is it a light blue on this map or
a dark blue
white blue all right so it's a little
light blue that goes just like
representative simpson said duh
it's it's saying tada here i am i am
hamstad
and i'm moving
okay
questions for representative wilhelm
all right
the other proposal 18b
representative barry
yes madam chairman thank you um
this map is a another congressional
district map that has a deviation of 0.0
percent uh
it's a deviation from zero is 88 uh 88
and 189 in the other because if you take
the state's population divided by two
you get a not whole number
so
things that we considered were we look
at
the the current way
that the the maps are situated which is
that you have let's take my state rep
district not that we consider state rep
districts inside
of other districts we didn't do that for
county commissioners but i represent
southern manchester in the town of
litchfield
manchester is in cd1 and litchfield is
in cd2
that's because over the years as
representative wilhelm
acknowledged over 140 years these
districts
have grown and mutated
the southern tiers continue to be
divided
in an attempt as he says to balance it
out which ends up with a district
as it is today
with its
jagged edges and its
inclines and
i look at it and i say okay
why can we not put the majority of
manchester southern tier back together
so i say okay we say okay
let's get hudson
wyndham litchfield
pelham
and salem and atkinson back together
with the rest of rockingham county
and the rest of southern hillsboro with
the exception of nashua because of
population differences
and as representative wilhelm said the
population differences from the existing
congressional districts were already off
by you have the exact number but let's
say 18 000 for the sake of simplicity
that means that cd1
already had to give
9 000
people over to cd2
and then we bring in the other southern
tier towns that i just mentioned
so now we must balance that out
and
the thing about what makes congressional
district mapping difficult
is that new hampshire gets two
congressional seats
we also use the component method we this
committee voted unanimously that we do
not break up towns right we don't put
half of dairy window one and half of
darien to another so because of that
you're moving large puzzle pieces
and as we know
different towns have different density
populations so when you move the
residents of hamps of oxygen hampstead
of salem windham
litchfield
pelham and atkinson over
you have to backfill that
and there's really
only one there's only really one place
to go
and that is the densely populated towns
of portsmouth
dover
durham and rochester
and that is that is how this map was
arrived to
it meets the constitutional requirements
of one man one vote
88 people
it meets the constitutional requirements
for the state of new hampshire it is
perfectly contiguous
okay thank you
questions
representative smith
marjorie
i'm sorry representative i can't i can't
hear you
let's try this am i on now thank you um
using the vernacular can you tell me why
we don't adopt the principle
of if it ain't broke
don't fix it
when we can by moving one town
and keeping everything else basically
the way it has worked well over the
years with districts going back and
forth in terms of
recognizing that we are a purple state
why would we
do something as dramatic as this and
although it is true
that every town
in each color whether it's light blue or
dark blue does touch another one
having um
this
construction just come up through the
middle
of the state
um
seems a little strange to me
understanding that
in order to get from my town
of durham to other towns in that
district you'd have to cross
the width
of
of the other district it does
i go back to my initial question if it
ain't broke why fix it um so a couple of
things to that point representative the
first is the premise is that it's not
broken
um
my definition is i wanted to see the
rest of the southern tier put back
together i consider that broken
to your point about driving from one
part of the district to the other i've
heard this one a lot
so i'd like to propose a road trip
from salem to berlin
under the current map
you will start in cd2
you will go into cd1 up 93 then you go
back into cd2 then you go back into cd1
and then you go back into cd2
that's a trip from salem to berlin north
to south
as i said earlier
we have two congressional districts
there is no map that you can make that
where you will drive from one part of
the state to the other
will not come in and out of a
congressional seat it's just by virtue
of the state's population
so i i enjoy the road trip theory um if
you're using the road chip theory then
representative porter
thank you madam chair am i on or off
mike put it closer yeah
that's your mic
yes okay um thank you madam chair and
thank you representative
chair and thank you representative so if
i'm understanding you correctly
your sole
criteria for changing this map was to
make sure those southern tier towns
are back connected with manchester that
was your main criteria and in order to
do that it meant
taking a whole bunch of towns
out of the district along the seacoast
is that or the
you know basically the sea coast and up
into uh maine is that what you're
telling me um no ma'am chairman i'm
stepping ships you know no
representative um as i said beginning my
main
my main criteria was create was for the
committee was to create a district that
met the constitutional requirements of
the united states of america and the new
hampshire state constitution after that
obviously a variety of other factors
come into place i do represent the
southern tier of new hampshire part of
it not all of it
so it was close to home for me and as
somebody who currently represents two
congressional districts in the southern
tier
it was definitely a factor of
consideration
thank you
um
weber in a minute maybe i'll go to
representative wilhelm and maybe
representative berry i'm i'm finding
this if it ain't broke
uh don't fix it argument sort of curious
because
um
i don't know how you determine whether
it's broke or not i mean are you
determining whether it's broke or not by
the partisan result
um because it would seem to me that
would be the only measurable criteria to
make that determination
and then the other question i had was
representative wilhelm i had no idea
these districts sort of had this type of
a line for so long do you know how
this type of a line was developed in the
first instance
so
and then maybe
could i answer since i was the one who
said if it ain't broke
um
i don't want to put that burden on
anyone else if i could respond to that
and what i meant i believe
representative wilhelm referred to the
fact that it had worked well but go
ahead representative smith i'll defer to
you as i see representative wilhelm
nodding um i'm sorry i missed that
i i said it because
the population difference was 18
in a state with
1.3 million people and so it meant
that the smallest possible possible
adjustment
could result in the district numbers
being evened
with the smallest number of towns and
cities having to make any changes
and it was perhaps it was too glib of me
to say it in that way
but what i meant is a very small
adjustment in this case one town could
give us the right number with the right
deviation
and in that case um
i thought the simplest approach was the
best approach all right thank you
because then that's consistent with i
believe representative bergeron's
comments yesterday about not wanting to
confuse voters by changing the districts
too much because i think under the logic
that you are just doing a population
would allow you to draw a line pretty
much in any direction through the state
when you only have two districts
but representative wilhelm if you wanted
to add anything to that question or as
to the origin of the original district
that would be helpful
um i think the origins of the original
district i think we should go to
uh house research i think we should we
should look it up no i just thought you
might know because you happen to know it
was 140 i had no idea no i just know
that there have been minor changes made
over the last several redistricting
cycles um
i do think that
you know when we talk about the the
districts as they exist right now we've
seen pretty competitive congressional
elections where voters have
uh you know a clear choice between
uh the two major parties and i think
that's ultimately i think that serves
our democracy pretty well
thank you representative ross do you
have an answer to either one of those
questions yes ma'am chairman i'm i'm not
as i'm not i'm not going to hold myself
up as an expert into the 140 year
history of the congressional districts
but in my research um and this is cited
in multiple websites you can go look
my understanding is that manchester and
nashua were split intentionally
to dilute the catholic vote and the
white ethnic vote
please go look it up so
you know
it happened many many many many many
years ago
it would say from my understanding it's
something that if any
elected
any elected body attempted to do today
would be ruled grossly unconstitutional
but it's one of those things that
derives when you have something that old
is you run into things like that where
you have
lines drawn to dilute religious
populations
which by the way is not something that
we would support obviously the map that
this side of the committee is bringing
forward still splits up manchester and
nashua but i assure you it is not to
dilute the catholic vote
thank you madam chair and i assure you
that our maps were not
drawn to dilute any one particular group
of persons vote as they stand now either
whatever the historical
reality was
what i want to ask is we i keep hearing
the phrase keep the southern tier
together
and as i'm looking at this map i'm
wondering what the heck the southern
tier is because
uh if we look at the most southern
border there are about nine or ten towns
that are abutting massachusetts
which don't seem to be part of the
southern tier
uh and yet the southern tier goes almost
halfway up the map into territory that's
for those of us who do live in the
southern part of the state seems fairly
far north
i'm i'm just wondering about the fact
that
at least half of the lower third
representative barry yes madam chairman
um perhaps i chose my words poorly um
but the
the concept is still the same i wanted
to bring hudson
pelham
litchfield salem and windham back
together
into one seat with the towns that they
neighbor
but you still have to consider the
population as a whole
right so it's just it's just one of
those things is when you look at a map
people want to believe that somehow the
population is evenly dispersed across
the entire state that is not the reality
representative wilhelm and i live in a
city that has a hundred and fifteen
thousand people
geography based geography wise we touch
towns that are the same amount of
landmass that have a population a third
of that and you can imagine going across
the state and across the southern tier
the sort of problems that that creates
and as i said in the beginning my goal
was to bring the towns i just mentioned
together and i we had to find a way to
and as a follow-up madam chair follow-up
representative i would just say that
backfilling towns together by also
joining together towns that are as
disparate as the ones that have been
joined in this plan
uh seems objectionable to me and i thank
you thank you
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair representative barry um
i was going to ask the similar question
that representative weber asked that
essentially your proposal
reduces the cohesiveness of the southern
tier
since under your proposal
everything from nashua to the western
border is now the southern tier where as
previously it was started further
further east but be that as it may you
you said that you wanted to uh bring
hudson windham and salem together again
and i'm curious as to
how they were ever together in the first
place
um
i said again i'm sorry i did i didn't
mean again if i did say again
i'm not saying i'm not saying i didn't
say it i don't recall saying it but i
wanted to bring them together okay and
then my question is
why did you want to do that because once
we know in redistricting once you make
one change that has a cascading effect
and by putting those large towns
together you created this cascading
effect which
creates a a district right in the middle
of the state with uh the other district
and
enveloping it or enveloping it on both
sides is kind of bizarre but be that as
it may i just if you could answer the
question why you chose to make that big
change create the cascade effect and and
in effect change 18 000 people instead
of um you know the the 10 000 that a one
town change would have made i'm correct
and remember representative this is the
this is um
this is the majorities committee map
it's not my map
um but the
they get the member we're dealing once
again we're dealing with the population
right
and western rockingham
and south and eastern hillsborough
county
repres in my opinion up until certain
point of rockingham represent what i
consider the the southern tier
of new hampshire the distinct region of
it
um
they have been they have been driven
further and further apart the map that
your party has proposed further
separates them by removing hampstead
those sort of things are going to
continue as the population shifts
it's just a matter of of priorities and
these towns have been apart for some
time and i think it's time that all that
area gets put back that not put back
together but put gets put together
representative simpson
thank you madam chair mine is more of a
comment is that all right sure um
which is i'm from the seacoast region of
the state and i just want to point out
that
um this map presented by the majority
really breaks up the seacoast that has
been together in the first congressional
district um the towns of well city of
portsmouth
and durham and other towns surrounding
it have um a great affinity and uh
shared
not um
well maybe most importantly but at least
greatly um in each in economy together
they have a shared um
they have a lot of things in common but
economically we talk a lot about the
seacoast as opposed to just the towns
and the seacoast so just to be clear
putting back together some of the towns
in the southern tier breaks up the
region of the seacoast
thank you
okay i saw another hand over here that i
hadn't heard from representative lane
um actually i was going to bring up the
same point that
representative simpson brought up which
was
you are breaking up an entire area of
the state with this map the seacoast
area
and when you look at it um
i
there are some i don't understand how
you can say it's the southern region
when there are towns that are
southern of the northernmost
parts of the state and the logic escapes
me and i know this is mathematically
driven but we also want to take into
communities of interest
and i don't see how
the seacoast area and the
have the same concerns as keene and
plymouth and all these others
that are included here and it it's
it is it's a question of why was that
not taken into consideration that you
are breaking up an entire area
of this of the state
i'm going to recognize representative
smith steve smith
yeah so um i live
seven miles from the vermont border and
we're talking a lot about
what goes on in the southern right
corner of the state and i'd kind of like
to offer my perspective and maybe it
will put some of those in context i
think representative barry
were
picking on the word that he used
southern cheer and then trying to define
that he listed the communities and agree
or disagree with his strategy i think he
was fairly specific so for me
i'd like to stop picking on the words
and
just to accept his argument for which
communities he wanted to put back
together and i say that as someone who
will never get a good solution out of
these maps
the uh the town of webster which is
probably 20 miles from the vermont
border has a traffic light it's a
blinking one but by god they got one
that's the area i represent
my congressman also represents nashua
what kind of sense does that make or
salem or colebrook
you can literally drive through one of
the most populous cities in the state i
don't know is nashville the most
populous it's the second most popular
manchester's probably the most populous
okay either way second most populous
city in the state
all the way to the canadian border from
massachusetts and you pass through where
i live
so
maybe for me
the community arguments
they just don't swing that much weight
because cd2
is and always will be if we do it this
way
the most screwed up district there is
now while i'm criticizing i tried doing
congressional maps myself to get what i
wanted
and i i don't want to be in the district
with nashua i don't want to be in a
district with salem i don't want that
can i make a map of mostly smaller towns
no i didn't it was going great and then
i think what happens when you make these
maps as you get to the end and you have
that unacceptable level uh number of
people that you just can't get rid of
without starting at the very beginning i
spent a lot of time doing that so for me
i i accept representative barry's
argument he has a rationale for what he
did you can disagree with it but he has
one
and recognizing that if you fix that
you're still never going to solve my
problem and
that's just how it is
thank you very much
madam chair
i heard something that representative
barry said and i'm concerned
that
when not be fair to one of our
colleagues
unless i miss her representative you
said
this isn't your map and if that's so
then i don't think you should have to
take the slings and arrows
and that and that concerns me i mean i
then want to know whose map it is but i
i i heard that comment and i
i felt bad for you
first of all representative thank you um
sometimes drawing the short straw
means that you draw the short straw um
everyone uh i'll just pipe in in that i
was contacted by somebody who apparently
got the map on
the pdf file and saw my name on it and
attributed it to me
so depending on the moment in time i
guess we're attributing maps to whoever
is the closest name go ahead as we've
conducted these work sessions um
representative marjorie smith i'm only
using your first name because
representative steve smith is here um
but
he doesn't want to be confused with me i
know that
but um
you know as as we've been doing these um
we've been doing and your side has been
doing as well one one representative
presenting one map um so
once again short straw i'm sure you know
i knew in this one when i drew this one
that no one would be interested in this
and that everybody was really here to
talk about the state rep seats and the
county commissioner seats and that this
was kind of begun after thought
that was a joke we can laugh
representative lane
uh thank you madam chair with all due
respect to representative stephen smith
no one has answered my question which is
why would you want to separate an entire
section of the state
away and divide it up
in connection when you don't have to
representative lane i i think i'll come
back to the legal principle that you
don't always get the answer you want to
a question but you get the answer
so
representative berry i'll go to that but
i will also point out that there are no
defined sections of the state
we have a state we have to create two
congressional districts we have health
and human service districts which are
different from county districts which
are different from town lines which are
different of course from the lines
within them so when one talks about a
section
it is hard to do that without defining
a section and i know that representative
simpson referred to the seacoast
area but i'm sure that there are towns
that uh might say they are or are not i
know that for years i have gotten in
discussions with people about what
states are in new england
i'm sure many of you have
been into that as to whether there are
four or five or six states in new
england representative barry i'm to that
point madam chairman
one of my favorite things about living
in new hampshire is that if you ask
somebody from the northern part of the
state if they live in the north country
the answer is of course i live in the
north country until you talk to somebody
who lives in the town just north of them
and they say no no i live in the north
country that's not the north country
down below
it's all relative but the current map
that your party has brought forward does
in fact split up regions of the state um
you know it's just once again going back
to the populations
we have for whatever reason prioritized
the
southeast corner forever
and maybe it's time that some of these
other towns and sections of the state
get put together instead of just one
section you're trying to balance the
population
representative wilhelm thank you madam
chair i just want to point out and i i
don't have the exact numbers on me but
it appears that approximately
25 about a quarter of the state is
moving from one congressional district
to the other and this is it's a pretty
dramatic
difference
uh from the the current maps and
you know
i took congressional elections when i
was in grad school at unh and my
professor
dante scala tweeted out this morning he
said
uh
that he and his research assistant had
been
drawing maps and they could not find
uh they could not draw a map that had
more partisan advantage than this one
right here so i just want to state that
for the record it's concerning to me
it's a massive overhaul of what we have
and it's very concerning to me
thank you representative barry you know
to that point um we discussed yesterday
and maybe representative would like to
point out where is the legal standard to
consider the current map it does not
exist the courts have ruled against it
multiple times
and in fact this very committee
discussed yesterday that it was not a
factor
we i believe we talked about i believe
your side was talking about drawing
districts around incumbents and we
refuted that no we didn't no oh no
madam chair and i don't think that's
what we were saying yesterday
representative i'm sorry that i feel
like i've been misrepresented in that i
simply made a comment yesterday
i'm wondering
i'm not a political scientist and i
haven't been part of this whole
deliberation that you're doing but i do
know that when it comes time to run for
office there are people who tell me um a
number that goes along with my district
it might be r plus three
or d plus one
or deep neutral
when we are
you both sides were
con
configuring this congressional map
were you using numbers like that to help
you make your decision
representative smith
oh representative lynn
sorry what i
i'm sorry
i was not in involved in the details
because of of the drawing of the match
because i have to tell you i don't
unlike some of my colleagues i assume on
both sides i don't know you know if you
ask me if you asked me before this
exercise let's say was conway a
republican or a democratic leaning town
i frankly i think i would have said
republican i've since learned that it's
not it's actually a democratic leading
town so i didn't and that's sort of my
ignorance
generally now if you ask me my town of
windham sure wyndham is a
republican-leaning town i ran you know i
ran in windham so i i understand that
but i guess
i guess what
if if
your question is
were political considerations something
that were in the mix
of course they were that's part of and
you know that that this is a political
process as the supreme court has
said repeatedly both the new hampshire
supreme court and the u.s supreme court
this is a political process that's why
it's done by the legislature so was that
something that was taken into account of
course it was
thank you
follow up before uh representative lane
and uh
i'm going back to representative wilhelm
who said that he felt the current map
uh was a very good map and
produced good results and i i i know i'm
sort of paraphrasing but you you went
back to talk about how you felt as a
base district to work from the current
cd produced results that indicated they
were good so i and i'm paraphrasing
which is why i'm coming back to you for
that
i think i talked about the
competitiveness competitive
competitiveness
serves our democracy well because then
it's a battle of ideas between the two
parties the two candidates who will
emerge
as the nominees for the general
elections i think that's a good thing
and so was competitiveness a factor that
you used in regards to the composition
of the maps and if so how did you
measure it
uh i think
competit i think
them to be competitive i know the two
districts that they're you know
consistently called by the
the
you know the the two parties they say
we're gonna
compete in
in new hampshire you know in both cd1
and cd2 cycle after cycle so what have
the results been in cd1 and cd2 since
the last redistricting to show that
they're competitive
uh i'd have to look back but i think i
think you could look at the results and
i don't know that there have been
blowouts and i'm concerned that the maps
that are presented there are going to be
blowouts in both 81 and cd2 so your
concern is as to the results of a
um
and if so did that logic carry through
for all of the maps
are we talking are we still talking
about the congressional maps well the in
the first instance but if
competitiveness is shown by close
results was that a factor since that was
a factor are you saying it was a factor
in this map or you just know it to be
true
uh i know it to be true and i think we
could look back at the last cycle and
we'll we would see that to be true so
that's what that's what my gut tells me
i'm just i'm just being okay
all right um where was the other hand
representative weber
oh i'm sorry representative lane
go ahead representative webber well i'm
just
sort of trying to
think off
representative lynn's comment
having been involved in redistricting 10
years ago
republican
house that was a legislature that was
three to one and um
they they could have controlled
they they had a majority that didn't
have to think about a gubernatorial veto
and they could have passed any map that
they wanted to but they chose
to keep the maps relatively
close to what they had been
and just make minor adjustments for
population so
i'm wondering why the majority decided
to take a completely different approach
this time
i would have no way of actually allowing
that question to be answered by anybody
on this committee unless they were on
that committee because i am not aware of
any
uh guidance issued
i i'm just asking about
you know the basis for currency were you
on
i think you were involved in that
process i'm the last
survivor
so as the last survivor you raised the
question do you have any knowledge i am
asking about not what happened then but
i am using it for a basis to ask about
what's happening now i think rep
representative barry already presented
that answer as to what his approach
was in explaining the map that's being
presented
for
uh
cd
representative lane did i i think i just
passed you over i apologize
representative
to representative len's point
yes it is a political process but
yesterday the majority
several times spoke
about how incumbents and how fair maps
were to be drawn ignoring the political
piece of it as much as possible
so i would just remind the majority that
they that was said when we were
reviewing maps yesterday for the house
i also just want to make it clear that
when representative piedra spoke about
um the the uh
it was in the commissioner maps that it
would not up you know
require any of the incumbents to not run
it was just it just happened it was not
an intent and i think he made that clear
and i would really appreciate it if
people
would stop referring to the fact that we
drew
maps around incumbents because i can
tell you there are people in our party
who are not happy with our maps
so thank you
it doesn't take long for me to perhaps
not remember exactly the same something
that was said as the person sitting next
to me so
thank you for your clarification of what
was said representative barry uh yes to
respond to representative lane um
that was how i interpreted his remarks
i'm i'm sorry that that's that's how i
misinterpret it but i i did we did probe
him um and i was one of the people that
probed him on that point about looking
at the districts and the current
incumbents um and that's what we took
away from it um i would never intend to
mischaracterize your position um but
that that is that is what he took away
from it um uh you're saying now that
that that's not and that i
misinterpreted that and i take that on i
take that as a good faith statement
yes i'm saying that you misinterpreted
it
okay well then a number of us probably
did so we will take that
consideration
all right
other hands
on this
earlier this summer the governor said
that he uh if it did pass the smell test
that he would reject a map
has anyone consulted the governor on
this proposal
does it pass his smell test
i am going to say that is beyond the
consideration of this committee the
governor ex it's part of the executive
branch this is the legislative branch
the presses the press or anyone as an
elected member is free to contact the
governor's office in regards to this map
this is a consideration for this body
going forward and
i can
and
to not go down the line of possibly
speaking of anything i i will just say
that i certainly have never spoken to
the governor or anybody in the
governor's office on this this is a
legislative body and i can tell you i
spend much time admonishing my
colleagues in regards to
continuing to recognize the separation
that the constitution has provided us
and i think both member all members of
each party around this table regardless
of who is sitting in the corner office
across the street is always aware of the
road ahead
and what bumps twists and turns may be
coming
further question
further question follow-up so are you
saying that i know you said you haven't
but no one i'm not i'm going to rule
that question out of order that is as to
a different branch i
just as i would rule out of order a
question as to whether or not the chair
of
um
i'm not even going to go there okay
representative wilhelm
anybody else
all right i just checked on my phone for
the website to see if there had been
progress made in posting these maps
online i do not see them yet i am going
to follow up with that now the next
session
is
going to be in reps hall we will be
together in reps hall next tuesday
at 10 o'clock
and
that should be in the calendar today
which same calendar just reminded me i
have something i have to get done by the
cutoff representative turcotte briefly
thank you madam chair i just want to
make a quick comment about the county
my personality is to be as judicious
with our time as possible i chose not to
read in all the districts on those maps
i have no problem reading those into the
record my assumption was those maps
would be posted online
we would
receive public input on them next week
at our public input sessions
and the following week we would be
having a robust discussion about
the differences in the maps presented so
i'm not opposed to reading them in if
you'd like to no we're not going to do
that now representative turcotte we have
moved on representative weber
um i think that was a hint given given
your ruling um i i don't need to comment
further on it
thank you representative porter i just
wanted to say thank you to the members
of the committee for welcoming me
welcoming me in and accepting my
questions
thank you it's always a pleasure to have
you and i know your district
and i was happy to hear your comments on
it
all right we are finished with business
for today i will see you or
or
a member hopefully maybe representative
simpson who at this point is
member
15a
of the committee next tuesday at 10